today we have a super special special
special guest David Eagleman is a world
renowned neuroscientist and a
best-selling author he's also an adjunct
professor at Stanford University at the
Medical School and he is the writer and
presenter of the international PBS
special series of brain with David
Eagleman and if I listed all of his
accomplishments recognition awards I
promise you we would be here all day
so I encourage you later to google it
and see you that long list yourself
essentially his work spans the physical
and a metaphysical and he's really
trying to understand what makes us tick
and how do we enhance that experience
and I have to admit that I am an
ultimate fangirl as a neuroscientist
myself I was first introduced to David's
work when I read an article about him in
The New Yorker in 2011 and it blew my
mind his curiosity and creativity are
amazing he was doing work at that time
I'm going to guess you still are on how
the brain processes time I mean so
interesting and then he goes about
trying to figure out how to actually
solve those problems and in addition
he's an entrepreneur because he takes
the things that he's learning and he
then translate them into products that
can help all of us so um I also love the
fact that I think it's your first book
some is some your first book his first
book is actually science fiction and
this book some is a collection of really
short essays about what happens to us
after we die now you might say what's
that about but really it's a book about
philosophy sort of understanding more
about what life is about by looking at
it through the lens of science fiction
so I want to start out with a question
for you about the role of science
fiction in science yeah okay good
question first of all thank you so much
for being here I really appreciate it so
I just mentioned you early on Friday and
became the scientific advisor for West
old HBO shows anyone watch Westworld
here's okay so that really got me
thinking about this question about the
how close science fiction is to the
practice of science in the laboratory
because what's going on with West world
is they think ahead thirty years and
they think they will pass silicon packs
the next technology you know how would
we build a brain what would that be out
of and so on and what's cool is they get
to be rooted in what we know about
science but also to have wings and to go
and sink a few steps beyond and really
when practiced correctly that's what
science is science is about making these
really that are actually illegal to make
it can't even make it then you look back
and you see if you can build a bridge to
what we already know so so science
fiction there's sort of this interesting
place where they overlap where I think
the best kind of science gets done where
you generate possibilities and see which
ones might be true so the way I hope to
structure our time together is that I'm
going to ask a bunch of questions the
beginning related to science and your
research and then move into questions
about entrepreneurship and about how
you're applying this and then I'm going
to open up to questions from the
audience
so you can start thinking along the way
of the type of burning questions you
have that you might want to ask toward
the end so we have a lot of engineers
who are in the room and these engineers
deal with sensors of all different types
their light sensors sensors and pressure
sensors and heat sensors and chemical
sensors and you are an expert on sensors
in the body what does an engineer need
to know about the type of sensors we
have in our body and how the brain
processes them so this is a topic that
I'm so interested for many years and I
started to take sort of sort of extremes
view on this which is I think that all
the particulars sensors we have for
electromagnetic radiation and air
compression waves and molecules floating
the air and so on I think these are all
plug and play receptors and that the
brain is sort of a general computational
device and you can plug whatever you
want here and the brain will just figure
out what to do with it and when you look
across the animal kingdom you find all
kinds of weird and interesting
peripheral devices that are plugged into
whether that keep its or magnetite so
they can line to the magnetic field of
the year or electroreception or
you know any kind of thing that you know
like the star-nosed mole has this thing
as this nose with 22 fingers on it then
it feels around it it's just a free
dimensional model and so on you've got
only different peripheral devices and so
the thing they're going to be really
interested in while ago is because you
have can we build new peripherals can we
build a new sort of thing where we're
plugging information into the human
brain via an unusual channel so one of
the things that we did in my lab you
probably know about this of course is
the we we we built this vest actually
brought a demo along here so I could
show you guys
we built this vest where we can I can
capture sound so as I'm speaking this is
picking up what I'm saying
and then what I do is I wear this vest
that picks up on the keep their clothes
yeah not just what this is by the end of
the talk will be the full-body that yes
so what's going on is the the sound is
getting picked up and translated in
patterns vibrational I bought each of
these are vibratory motors and so what's
happening is as I speak the sound is
getting captured and turn into panic
vibrations and deaf people can come to
understand the world this way
and they can come to hear the world
through patterns vibration on their
torso and so this is you know it sounds
wacky it's essentially like the way a
blind person can read a Braille novel
and you know cry and laugh based on the
information coming through their
fingertip right so it's the same sort of
thing since we're taking the inner ear
the cochlea and putting it on the torso
and the parts that's been of great
interest to me is you know there are 53
million deaf people in the world who are
severely or profoundly deaf and so we
can just cure that now for under a
thousand bucks that we're the only other
solution for deafness or the cochlear
implant which is a hundred thousand
dollars an invasive surgery so this is
something that's going to change the
whole world so I'm very jazzed about
that but I'm also interested in this
issue about censoring addition so if
you're not deaf and put on the vest can
we feed in new kinds of information
brave and have you have a completely new
kind of sense a a sixth sense so we're
trying all kinds of things we're feeding
an information about drones or factories
or stock market data or weather data or
Twitter data we're feeding in all kinds
of information streams into the body
this way and seeing how you can develop
a new sort of sense and anyway so this
is this is where we are with that super
said I'm wondering is it like an echo I
mean if you're talking and then you're
feeling it on your body does it feel
like an echo of your voice so when a
baby is learning how to speak that will
they say things when they hear it with
their ear it's exactly the same you say
it you feel it on your torso so it is
like connect on the same way that you
share what your own speeches but we're
very good at cancelling out our own
speech you don't really pay attention to
it anyway it's the same thing this is by
the way really important way that deaf
people learn how to speak is you know
they not only like watch your lips of
their affiliates but they vocalize and
feel what they're saying and that's how
they know what is super interesting do
you think that their senses that we have
that we actually haven't characterized
yet I mean we've got our five senses
that we all know about and we learn
about since we're little kids but do you
think that there's some senses we
haven't even characterized no with the
exception of um some college my made
this thing called the North paw which
just is a compass assist up to a
vibratory belt that tells you where
North is so people get really good at
being able to tell where North is but
after they take off the belt they're
much better at it than they were which
which tells me that there's some little
whisper of a signal in the brain anyway
maybe we have a little bit of magnetite
it's not not known yet now period we
have a little whisper of a sense being
able tell there's an F you clean up on
that correlate the signal then you're
better at super interest yeah right but
in general and generally we really cut
off from the world in a sense in the
sense that you know we got these
peripherals that we know and love like
our sight and sound and vision our touch
and smell and so on but in fact our
perception of reality is really
constrained by the biology that we come
to the table at the example I always use
is you know
electromagnetic spectrum that's what
color is you look around each other's
color in the world that's less than 1/10
trillion of the electromagnetic spectrum
gun cosmic rays x-rays and gamma-rays
you've got all these different
frequencies electromagnetic radiation
they're totally invisible to you all you
see is a little bit that we have
receptors for MRIs to pick up on the
rest you get thousands of cell phone
conversation passing through your body
and it's completely invisible to you why
because you don't come to the table to
proper biological receptors for picking
up on what could you imagine a time
where we would train ourselves to be
able to just listen to record cell phone
right as you just I can hear a call
coming in oh it's my mom yeah yeah and
that's precisely its it's the question
of what if we built new peripheral
detectors what can we pick up on that
we're not picking up now because as it
says now we're extremely constrained in
our reality now the issue is and some of
you have heard me talk about this before
but the issue is that we get used to our
a completely limited reality and we
start to believe that the whole world
out there we think that our subjective
world is the objective reality out there
which is so goofy because it only takes
you know a minute start realizing oh my
gosh it could be sensing this this and
this um you know the example I use it
about this often is just imagine for a
second that you are a bloodhound dog
with a you know they've got a big snout
you've got 200 million scent receptors
they have wet nostrils that are tracked
and traps scent molecules deaf slits in
their nostrils like anything those holes
there their floppy ears to kick up the
whole world without smell so imagine you
are that bloodhound dog and you're
following your human master one day and
you stop in your tracks and you think I
wouldn't like to have the impoverished
little nose of a human like how can you
not know that there's a cat 100 yards
away or that your best friend was on
this spot six hours ago that kind of
thing so because we are humans we're
totally used to being in this particular
you know sensing of the world and we
think there's nothing else but in fact
there's so much more we could be sensing
that's exactly what we're do
so what's really fun about my reading
your work and thinking about your work
is that I'm reminded of David Foster
Wallace where he doesn't sort of you
know what is water right you guys might
know the story the two fish are swimming
and the older fish comes by and says you
know how's the water boys and they go
what's water and you are one of the
people who thinks about what the water
is okay the things that we take for
granted and one of the things I think is
particularly interesting that is that
you you think about the way different
senses are experienced fire so why is it
that we have these different sensors
why is sight why does it feel so
different than sound and what is sound
feel so different than touch and what is
touch feels so different than taste can
you talk a little bit about your
thoughts yeah yeah I can go to my
hypothesis on this which is the weird
part about the fact that these all are
so different seeming to us on the inside
weird part about that is if you look in
the brain you see a bunch of neurons the
cell types of the brain and they're all
popping off you know every neuron in
your head is popping off about ten to a
hundred times per second and if I show
you a little piece of the cortex and you
see boom can I said that's the visual
cortex or the auditorium at sensory or
know like you say bio it looks exactly
the same a not as a you know as a
professional who looks at the stuff
every day I would have no idea what it
is why because it all looks the same on
the inside so why just validates why is
he seems so different and I think it has
my hypothesis on it that has to do with
the structure of the data coming in so
vision you have two 2-dimensional sheets
with data coming in hearing is a
one-dimensional signal Erb fingers are
picking up on this high
multi-dimensional signal you've got all
these different things come in and I
think that they are different because of
the structure what that means to me if
this is right that we feel in a totally
new kind of signal like it's a stock
market data here as somebody experiences
that for months and months
my hypothesis will start having new
qualia that's called a new experience
that not vision or touch or taste or
smell it's none of those it's this other
thing and the thing is we won't even
have a word for it language because
language is all done
shared things like I know visions you
know vision is so we can communicate
across the gap of our brains and we say
the thing but if I've experienced
something that you never had any
experience of I would say look I'm I'm
experiencing SH McGee and you wouldn't
know what I'm talking about
oh that's McGee yeah that interesting
part is like if you try to explain
vision to a blind person
they at some point they'll even start
pretending like they understand you but
they can't the liver understand you if
they're born blind because they've never
had that experience of capturing photons
in the distance and putting together
this you know colors which are clearly
made up by the brain I'd say you can't
explain vision to a blind person in the
same way that I couldn't explain to
McGee to you and the only way you would
ever know it is if you are the best and
also fed in stock market data and the
presumption is that you would start
experiencing this completely new Claudia
because the structure and the data is
different it's not like these other ones
probably do you think that at some point
we'd be able to read other people's
minds if we were getting neural input
from someone else this is this is an
interesting area in the field where
people have been using for example
functional magnetic resonance imaging
brain imaging to measure all kinds of
things and then try to see if we can
figure out something to do and a lot of
people talk about mind-reading but it's
only right over to visual cortex that we
can do that pretty well which is to say
whatever whatever is hearing your eyes
you have a sort of distorted picture
that on your visual cortex here so you
can use brain imaging and read that and
show people a lot of pictures measure a
lot of that and put together a neural
network and figure out what they must be
singing so it's called mind-reading but
it's actually unfortunate I think that's
kind of where N and being able to read
minds in different way like oh I'm
hungry I'm thinking about a burrito with
guacamole on earth there's no possible
way that we're even close to that
because it's a very different kind of
thing because it's not laid out in the
slice pattern the way vision is where
it's essentially a television screen
back here you know in school what we do
try to use PET scans to look at and sort
of Intuit what we think people might be
must be experiencing right so sort
wonder if you could read it out it's
SuperDuper limited and it's always for
several reasons one is that our
technology stinks right now so
fMRI is the hot thing that we all use in
our labs that we publish lots of papers
on it but it's stuck it's not it's you
know all you're measuring is where the
blood flow goes which is a proxy for
where the neural activity just was two
seconds ago and you're measuring these
chunks that have millions and millions
of neurons in them both excitatory and
inhibitory neurons in them so to crack
the neural code what we actually need is
to be able to measure individual neurons
in real-time and billions of them 100
billion of them essentially that's what
we're going to need to be able to
subtract the neural code so fMRI stinks
so that's the first thing when it comes
to I'm thinking about a burrito and that
reminds me of my hand who's from this
place and she once said this commune
there's there's no connection there was
what we're measuring out right yeah okay
so we've got a bunch of Engineers you're
going to be working on this now yeah
it's a good fun to work on for the
future so you think about sensory input
but the brain is also a motor output
system right so can you imagine using
these tools for actuation as well as
just for sensation yeah so something
like this is about building up more
sensations getting more sensory data in
there as far as getting information out
for that we need better ways to read the
brain obviously we have things like
electrons of la graffiti pg8
but that also is a stinky technology
essentially we're measuring from the
outside of this giant you know bony
armored bunker that Mother Nature has to
protect the pink computational substance
of the brain we're measuring from the
outside and you just can't tell that
much and you know here in Silicon Valley
I interact with a ton of companies that
all say oh if we can measure EG we can
tell this little thing but in fact we
can't tell very much with EEG and we
never will be able to so fMRI is better
because you can actually see what's
going on in there but it has low
resolution spatial and temporal
resolution so we need better ways of
getting in there but but people are
working on we're all working on our own
tech projects and ideas and I think as
the field creeps along there'll be these
punctuated the moments where we have
better ways of looking in it and then
then we can really start
we get down to the level of resolution
where we can crack the neural code and
there's like 20 Nobel Prizes that follow
on from there but one of the things that
I'm running about in my next book called
live wire is about brain plasticity and
one of the things I think it's
interesting is how our brain drives the
body and it can do so very flexibly so
you know I can you know what do I grow
from infant to an adults I'm driving a
very different kind of body so you get
the three-pound control center and then
this huge monstrous you know robot that
gets driven around but but I can get on
a bicycle or a surfboard or a skateboard
I can do all kinds of things my brain is
no problem suggesting and driving
everything so I think it will be no
problem at all for us to be able to
drive other kinds of scenery with our
brain whether that's driving a big crane
or you know taking my robot for a walk
on Mars where I'm controlling it or
wherever there's really there's no need
for the thing to even be attached to me
and I authorize that we'll be able to
drive it at a distance because Mother
Nature can have lots of great stuff
which never came up with Bluetooth and
so there's no reason that when I'm
controlling this limb that it could be
tapped from cool so I know there's a lot
of enthusiasm for virtual reality and
which is a wonderful way to control
sensor input in a really sophisticated
way do you do work with the arm and and
how do I like to your research um well
I'll tell you something that just struck
me recently about VR so many of you have
probably done something like this I did
this thing where in VR so this is at a
conference I watched several people
before me do and then I did get in this
thing
and in this VR world you get on one of
these window washer platforms and you
end up going 500 feet in the air on this
window washer platform in virtual
reality in fact you're standing on the
ground at the conference okay and then
you're at the very top you're
overlooking the city and suddenly the
front rail breaks off and falls off and
you're looking over the thing and then
you hear this voice telling you step off
the rail well it's just that I want so
much people do and they were too scared
and I thought there's no possible way
that I'll be too scared to do this
but then I was I was too scared to do
that because it was so unbelievably
convincing but here's the new part the
new part is we've never our evolutionary
history have a situation where I was in
two places of one Here I am standing
above this 500 foot you know view of the
city and I'm also in the convention
center and I knew that both things were
true at the same time and that is a
completely new phenomenon that you can
beat and you're Hannah finally Kingdom
Come I know that if I step to my death
it's okay because I'm in the convention
center so anyway I think there's a lot
to be mind there about consciousness and
how we understand our identity and where
we are and so on like that I'm also
doing stuff with the vest in VR by the
way this is more for entertainment but
the idea is we're putting a half extreme
into into the best so that as you are
playing a as you're playing a game where
you're like shooting and so on you're
feeling you're getting shot on the vest
we know when somebody's behind you're
above you or behind so it's a very cool
it's a very cool sensation I know when
you play VR without the haptic vessel
spin yeah so let's talk about that being
an entrepreneurial scientist right
students most scientists are there
writing publishing papers and they look
at their contributions of intellectual
value you are taking what you're doing
to the next level where you're saying
okay how do I take what I've learned to
really affect the world and the best is
one example can you talk about different
ways in which you're looking at the
potential for applying the things you're
learning yeah I am so I would love
talking about us because I actually just
made this change sort of two and a half
years ago so I've been running allowed
my whole career I've got you know almost
120 you know academic publications and
science and nature and so on and you
know maybe six people on the planet read
these things is making a long time to
figure that out and then you know and
then you get caught in these little
world war threes in the literature where
people that is
and nobody actually cares with the band
you know it seems to you in the moment
like it's the biggest meal what's the
right answer so I started getting more
interested in figuring out how do I make
the rubber hit the road and build things
that can affect fifty three million
people for example so so two years ago
this is an interesting moment for me
actually because I got invited to give a
TED talk on the best and and right when
I went out there to give this talk I
received two letters from NIH and NSF
rejecting a grandparent put it on the
back saying and I'm not making this up
one of the grant rejections said it's
not incremental enough and that's what
they meant by that is it's you know it's
like this really is very poor looking
thing and what I need to do is show this
and then show this and then spend those
four you're shown that anyways the
things I forgot the two rejection
letters I went out Ted I presented that
I showed what it could do I showed
videos of things happening it and and
all of these VCS they had they checked
already exactly well I got to take my
choice I get to talk to everybody in
that's saying okay you see what you did
the best match and so so we got funded
and it was a real change from there's a
real eye-opener for me so now the way I
see it is there's a spectrum consience
if equestions where government granting
is useful for some kinds of those
questions and VC funding is useful for
other kinds so now I'm sort of getting a
foot in both world and and you know
really trying to take advantage of the
big meaty questions that are that are
perfect for for VC funding so I started
this company neo sensory about the best
and that's going to like gangbusters we
just closed on office space just NL
communi and these are beautiful space
and it's just so much fun we're building
lots of innings we've got contracts with
lots of other companies now most which I
can't talk about actually but but we've
got cool contracts and things going on
and collaboration with other companies
who like our technology and and I
actually have three other companies that
are doing I kind of went nuts I started
company because it was because there's
just so much fun so let's talk about
that okay let's talk about and I want to
hear about the other companies bedford
how do you start three or four companies
at once what does that actually look
like i mean this is a class on
entrepreneurship that probably is not
something we would recommend so I know
okay so don't try this at home so why
not I'll tell you this trick that I got
really good at was starting to come up
getting everything joint you are having
the IP padding AP whatever and then
hiring a CEO or in some cases just a CEO
to you know to like need the daily stuff
and I'm not pretty good at like I'm
getting better at it but CEO is what I
was born to do
I was born to be more of the idea
generator and so it's been it's been a
really straightforward thing now that I
figured out the trick to it for myself
so so that's how I so what's a typical
day look like
okay computer you're writing books
you're starting me all these companies
we're doing research
yeah and I'm teaching here also so I
show up on Tuesday and Thursday mornings
here to peach and then what I do is I go
to the the office for neo sensory and
we're expanding rapidly we got about 20
people now and we're moving up to 30
pretty quickly here and so I'm just you
know trying to manage stay on top of all
the projects do the scientific feedback
on everything the sort of digging vision
stuff and yeah then I try to find
moments to write what I did actually is
I write my books on airplanes or my
airplanes all in crime and I'm a killer
on airplanes because there's nothing too
different in the seat and you can't make
any phone calls and you can't go
anywhere so you just work oh right there
okay great that's good at one point I
considered buying it checked it across
the nation in back just like that's a
good idea
so what are the other companies so one
is called brain check and we developed
you take tests on a tablet or on a phone
and we can very rapidly measure what's
going on under the hood so perception
reaction time decision-making cognition
of various sorts you just play the very
simple games in five minutes we can get
14 different measures of it's
essentially a very clear cognitive
snapshot of how you're doing then every
two months your phone pings you tells
you to take the brain checking in and
and we can tell when somebody starts
turning the car
to mild cognitive impairment which is
stage before dementia now the reason
that's so important is because once
somebody is fully demented it's too late
in terms of any sort of pharmaceutical
intervention in the stage of mild
cognitive impairment which is on the way
there there's lots of stuff that can be
done to slow that down the problem is no
one ever comes in to the neurologist and
their psychologist until too late and
it's because people have a million ways
of making excuses that
yes but it's up here I'm not gonna clean
whatever the thing is until it's way too
late and they come in this to it so what
we're doing is setting up with hospital
systems for that Emma can have this at
home and the hospital to provide the
continuance of care and the patient at
home can get somebody who cares about
their cognitive snapshot so that's brain
check we're all thinking that's a
concussion so we're lot specialty
colleges in the athletics we decided the
content for ESPN actually also for their
big tournament so dad right at the
sidelines you can test the money figure
out they've got a concussion because
what's really gets concussive or in
particular cognitive deficits that they
present with them so we can tell them
right there in the sidelines very cool I
know you're also really interested in
the interface between neuroscience and
the legal system and I think it's really
fascinating right the idea that the
legal system treats everyone as if
they're cognitively the same and yet
that isn't the case and what are your
thoughts on that so yeah I mean that's
exactly the issue is that we imagine
that incarceration is the
one-size-fits-all solution but in fact
the brains of show up in front of judges
bench can be very different from one
another so yes it's been eeeh this
person it's like a path for speak down
of drugs and so on and so on and and and
it suggests different routes forward for
all of them the important part is that
bring the neuroscience to understand
what's going on in legal system doesn't
let anybody off the hook it doesn't
exculpate anybody but what it does is it
tells us how to build a forward-looking
legal system one that cares about
actually solving the problem instead of
simply using jail as the only tool which
provably is criminal genic meaning it
causes more fun
because once you put someone in jail you
break their economic opportunities break
their social circles you give a new
economic opportunity new social circle
and and so people end up coming back
into prison that way so you know there's
we can be much smarter many of you
probably knows but maybe not all America
has the we're number one in the world
for our incarceration rate for the
number for the percentage of our
population that we put in jail there is
no country in the whole world
that puts a higher percentage of its
population in jail which means you know
it's actually the smartest thing that we
could do obviously not as I said it
causes more crime so yeah we there's so
many smarter tactics that we can take
and this is a big part of where the
intersection of neuroscience and legal
systems come into play and by the way
one of my startup companies develop it
okay well it turns out there's one
county that does something really smart
which is instead of arresting someone of
putting them in jail right away and then
they have to wait usually it's 48 hours
to see if the prosecutor is going to
prosecute that case or release it as and
no action case there's one County where
the police officer arrests somebody
calls up the 24/7 prosecutor hotline
talks to the prosecutor about the case
tells them the elements indicated the
prosecutor listens it okay let the guy
go there's not enough there to press
charges so the guy gets electorate there
instead of being put in jail for 48
hours which is enough to lose a job so
those are spouse things like that and it
saves millions Arthur so we're trying to
spread this around now so we built the
software that it's the whole secure
cloud-based software interface that
allows counties to run their legal
system where that part of it can you
intake system and the whole thing is is
one piece of software instead of what
currently happens which is the same
paperwork is enough for climbs
could you imagine the brain check
program also being used there to do an
evaluation maybe it depends on what the
person is getting stopped for but I am
very interested in using this for
something that the cops to tell fornia
are very worried about which is with the
legalization of marijuana
everyone in California is in favor of
this it's just for the cops you feel
like geez at me if there's more people
are going to be driving high and we've
got to get
worry about that the problem is there's
no breathalyzer equivalent to alcohol
when it comes to somebody driving hi
yeah it's coming too many gummy bears or
so on so anyway what I'm proposing is
using brain check as a very fast test
we're making a 30-second version where
you can tell just very liberally should
somebody be behind the wheel or not and
the cool part about it is there are
actually lots of reasons why somebody
shouldn't be behind the wheel it may not
be just marijuana but something a poly
pharmaceutical or their fatigue or
whatever but the thing is we can just
tell if they're above or below this line
and that gives probable cause to at
least say we need to take person off the
road very the who wants to ask the first
question and my focus is going to be on
students where students have slept in
yes so a personal web whole thing is
really cool and seems like you're pretty
rapidly moving into this area of
celebrity scientists show say like
Stephen Wolfram and you'll regret Tyson
have a really large public voice and
that's really awesome because it brings
science to the mattress but one of the
challenges associated that is both
making it timely and accessible and not
putting forwards and information that
can not only be misconstrued
but can we something people making
conclusions and forming companies on
things that you wholly do not agree so
how do you kind of hit your bets they're
all at the same time asking the public
and spreading the message anymore yeah
thanks for that question it's really
important I'm teaching this class now
called public communication in
neuroscience and my general feeling on
this is it actually it's this middle
road between as you said you know
getting people care about something and
not having misinformation about
something there's this middle road where
you do both pieces right it's actually a
wide road I've never actually found that
that challenging so you can look at my
books and what I do with my books just
as a side note is I have lost lots of
references so I make sure that
everything is super thoroughly
referenced with the papers literature
and so on um I don't know if anyone's
seen my television show the brain but
you know it's I think it's very
entertaining but it's all completely
nailed down stuff like there's nothing
in it that's
that's controversial or hard and and I
think that it's not actually a challenge
to get on that reload so one has to be
extended is what I'm teaching this class
it's extrude it's 100% important to make
sure always on that road and not off you
know saying something that's not
accurate something like that but it's
image it's not that hard to stay on the
middle uh if you're going to come to the
classes on Tuesday Thursday more
anything tell you or anyone else who
wants to show so I I wanna I want to
build on that though please you you sort
of implied that we know how the brain
works there like there's nothing
controversial so where you see study the
studies but I'm curious where do you see
the biggest mysteries these days I
wasn't I did my PhD in neuroscience and
I was joked that you know if someone had
told me at the beginning that we don't
know how the brain works are going to
save me a lot of time so I'm curious
what mysteries you really wish we could
unravel so I wrote I wrote actually the
cover article of Discover Magazine back
in 2006 called 10 unsolved mysteries of
the brain which I outlined what I
thought were the ten biggest mysteries
the interesting part the reason I
mentioned that that was 2006 because
they are still direct now in its y17 so
here I would say two things that are
both important one is that so for
example I wrote this textbook on
cognitive neuroscience which is 674
pages of unbelievably dense stuff and
the thing I want to say is that it's not
that we don't know anything about the
rangas we know what's fun about the
brain we know a lot of what's going on
but if you compare it to the uncharted
waters ahead of us you know it's still
uncharted waters as far as we can see so
I just want to make both points it's not
that we don't know anything we know a
lot and it's not that we know it all
because there's a huge amount that we
don't know big questions to my mind are
things like consciousness we don't know
why it feels like something to be alive
and to be conscious because you know we
can build physical stuff which is all
the brain is it's 100 billion neurons
and neurons are extraordinarily
complicated and so on but but it's
nonetheless stuff as far as we tell
every neuron is driving every other
neuron and it's all you know a machine
of a sort and so the question is how do
machines come
to have their own experience why does
you know the taste of feta cheese or the
smell of cinnamon or something if I if I
feel coming out a tinkertoy and I put if
I gave you 100 billion Tinkertoys now
he's putting together in any
configuration you want at what point to
you add one more ticket on you say ah
now it's experiencing the beauty of a
sunset or the redness of red or the pain
of pain or something like that not only
do we not know how consciousness works
we don't even have a good theory that
gets us all right we can say oh I can
carry the two now there's nothing so so
that's a big giant mystery but there are
lots of them you know about why do brain
sleep and dream I mean we spend a third
of our lives in this awful ganger state
and we don't exactly know what that's
about
that's weird you know what is
intelligence we know that it's something
and probably most people who's audience
were like among the most intelligent in
their high school and their hometowns
done but Josh we don't have a met we
don't know exactly what it is is it
about finishing possible futures and not
sucking distractors in the mouth on the
look so anyway there's lots of things
you know what our emotions our lives our
lavishly colored with emotion we only
have a very rudimentary understanding of
that kind of thing anyway yeah let's go
it's job security right I mean I
couldn't look at that ones around guy
drops again so one of the things that's
so interesting about neuroscience in
other areas of science as well is that
very much is affected by the type of
tools we have to study right you know
sort of looking under the light for the
keys right oh we now have this new tool
we're going to study everything through
that lens if you had a new tool to study
the brain what would that tool be so
this is only I spend a lot of my time on
I'm consulting for a friend of mine
named Brian Johnson who runs a company
called Colonel down in LA and the idea
is what kind of new neuro technology can
we build that can really allow us to see
into the brain eventually not only read
but write also what would that neuro
tech look
like and so I've spent a lot of my time
examining new AI incipient ideas for
neuro technology and where that's going
to go and you know here's what I would
say the kind of thing that we need is
something that can as I mentioned before
read at the level of individual neurons
spike by spike and can measure and
billions of those at once that it's not
going to be electrode implants which is
what a lot of people are are sort of
spending their time with because you can
do that in animals you can stick a but
it's totally medieval and you can't do
that in humans neurosurgeons aren't
going to do because there's risk of
infection and death customers aren't
going to do it because you don't what
are your get ahead surgeries so you can
better interface with your cell phone so
so what we need is something that is
non-invasive and has really good spatial
temporal resolution and so I'm looking
at various things involved this for
example nano robotics at least eight
years off of the idea people are working
on can you do three-dimensional
atomically precise printing of a little
molecule and if so can you build little
robots who just you know swim around and
pregnant Iran and then send off radio
signals we build a mesh network out of
this this is stuff that super cool it's
probably you know like because it was a
decade off before we even have a capsule
that you can swallow like this and then
it's a long way off before we would know
that it's safe to do and so on there are
all kinds of things happening with opto
genetics it's not clear how you can use
that in humans yet whether it's a useful
tool but it might become that so there
are lots of you know and there's ways of
sneaking up electrodes in vascular
system your your brain is shot through
with this whole tree like structure of
blood vessel pick up in there and listen
to what's going on through the middle
instead of the outside I think that's a
very interesting route for the future so
anyway there's all these things they're
just at the starting point right now but
this is what I mean it's a nursing
question because if you really could
listen to all the cells know would we
actually know what it was saying and
would that be I mean because there are
ten times as many glial cells in the
brain as there are neurons yeah so did
you yeah the glial cells aren't popping
off with information that's carrying
information Rapala so the glial cells
are doing important stuff for sure and
maybe even informational irrelevant
stuff but in a different time scale of
physics doing that at all the girls are
the ones are carrying information
rapidly so you can do stuff in the world
and reacted something and I think if you
could actually measure what the neurons
were doing but I mean they're taking the
enormous amount of data bigger than most
of the computers that we have even on
this campus but yes we could then crack
it it was employment you're probably
under graduation to crack the neural
okay so who wants to do an independent
study okay next question
yeah thank you for coming here I'm gonna
graduate on University and I would like
to ask you you know it's quite obvious
that we're very glued to our screen
these days and yet it doesn't seem to
make the technology that enhances our
senses but it is all you that it makes
us into more you know zombies zombie
like okay more like zombies
is it your logical explanation as to why
we're so glued to a screen
yeah I mean the rings are so good your
screen is because everything you care
about is there I mean you have a few
friends around you and you've got
thousands of friends right here and
you've got the entirety of humankind's
knowledge in a rectangle in your pocket
so that's pretty cool I'll tell you my
opinion on this which actual types you
think huh one is that it's proven very
hard to do good experiments on what what
the meaning of this is whether it's bad
for us or good for us and the reason is
it's it's almost impossible to find a
good control group so in other words if
you how do you you're you're 19 so if
you look for 19 year olds who didn't
grow up digital like you did you can't
really find them unless they're Amish or
they're terribly impoverished or
something and those aren't good control
group students and you can't compare you
the previous generation because there
are a hundred other differences there
just in terms of nutrition and pollution
but there's a million other news so the
thing is whatever it's trying to answer
is what does it mean for 19 year olds
grow up digital how does it change the
brain but it's not an easy question to
answer if you guys my opinion on it
I'm actually a real cyber optimist about
this I think that your generation is
going to be smarter than my generation
because of the following reason which is
that to make changes in the brain you
need the right cocktail of
neurotransmitters to be present for
things to actually detect a neural
plasticity to happen that cocktail
neurotransmitters that correlates with
engagement with curiosity and this is
something even the ancient Greeks should
notice they they outlined seven
different levels of learning the highest
level of learnings when you care about
something when you're curious about
something so when you want to know
something you look on Wikipedia right
away Brewers you get the information in
the context of your curiosity in
contrast with when we were in school we
got a lot of just in case information
just in case you ever need to know these
ten dates in Mongolian history here you
go but you're getting a lot of
just-in-time information and that makes
a big difference from the point of view
of neuroplasticity it makes a big
difference in terms of being able to
remember and recall things as you need
them
and what I think it means is that if you
if you had some way of visualizing the
entirety of the world's knowledge what
people growing up now can do is enter
from whatever angle they care about
whatever resonates for them whether
that's you know baseball or dancing or
whatever the thing is you can enter you
can yeah we all know what it's like to
get lost on some Wikipedia thread and
you end up start over here and the end I
want some of you have no idea what the
relationship is how you got there but
the point is you're surfing through the
world knowledge that way I think it's
really terrific for it to be
individualized like that so people can
do that so I have quite high hopes for
connection that's terrific right it's
just about billing on how he's mentioned
about consciousness and the tools to
understand how consciousness works and
so forth so we typically divide the role
in deterministic manner we think that
things tend to happen in a certain
certain formulaic manner and we're
trying to find this formula that
actually creates a deterministic
relationship receive what you think it
will happy next but what if the brain
actually doesn't work thing a
deterministic manner maybe it is a
stochastic or a random phenomenon
somehow and what's your thoughts on that
I mean how
yeah the question is what if the brain
is not deterministic but stochastic it
has randomness in it the answer is that
may well be there may be all kinds of
processes at the molecular level is
atomic level but the quantum level that
are doing that exactly so there's no
need for it to be deterministic the
question of consciousness is a separate
question it whatever is happening here
deterministic or stochastic how do why
does it feel like something in other
words the fight you know if I open my
garage doors my clicker you know I can
describe everything goes on but I don't
think that it has consciousness is
something it's just doing its thing it's
just following circuit or if I program
something awesome on my computer it's
just running through zeros and ones it
does a question that still stands
whether it's deterministic or stochastic
is why is it what do we have experience
why aren't we zombies that do everything
we talk about neuroscience is that oh
you know like this thing is convenient
and we react this way and so on but why
couldn't all that happen without any
experience of it at all anyway that's
the question which is a separate one
question yes is a totally open and
perfectly good question which is how do
we know which way this I'll just say one
thing on there really quickly which is
interesting which is that the question
of freewill do we have reading to
operate or are we just machines that are
you know extraordinarily complicated
interacting with other eternally
complicated machines and in social
networks it's on and the question is do
we have any freedom in how we operate
turns out that whether we are
deterministic or whether we are
stochastic makes no difference because
it's not freedom and either in either
case so this is something we all wrestle
with is how what would it even mean to
have freewill you literally feel like we
do feel like we make choices it might
all be an illusion but you know if we
were to try to find with freewill looks
like stochastic behavior doesn't save
that at all it's just as you know random
but it just is right randomness is not
free well and you know I'm just tossing
dice and it's not pretty well yeah
excuse me I'm going to go on to a
student okay we get our meal
I imagine your brain typing you at real
life stop leading to more incarceration
of people driving under the influence of
marijuana for example or procedures that
could replace the incarceration of
people who are at the port for
possession of marijuana which could be
soot that some outcomes maybe not but
you worry about your technology in
general seeing these particular dangers
again especially since you're coming up
with such innovative music on oh the
question is can any technology come up
with be used for evil things and am I
worried about my technologies that are
not being used for the in the wrong ways
I will say that in general we always
have to keep our moral compass ahead of
our technologies we always have to make
sure that we're leading in the right
direction in the case of the things that
I'm working on now I don't have any
concern about that in the case of
somebody being taken off the road
who is the low some very liberal
threshold where they are the absolute
shouldn't be on the road that actually
helps the world I think instead of hurts
the world and people won't necessarily
almost certainly it won't be
incarcerated
instead when we take it off the road
until they're able to drive again which
is a very different sort of thing than
increasing our incarceration rate and as
far as the vest goes you know there's so
I think about this question a lot thank
you for asking about this question if
how could somebody uses for bad purposes
I haven't been able to think of anything
yet that is that that's an evil bad
thing to do that's any different than
you know using cell phones or computers
or whatever so but this is an important
question that as all of us develop new
technologies we always need to stay on
top of that example so you mentioned
that your device is real enable the
human body to talk to people like whole
new variety of wavelength frequency the
human brain however is it's time to
prioritize only essential information
right like that essentially information
that will form and an entity
you're bein biotope so with a whole new
stream of people and signals are you
worried that the brain will eventually
over saturate and eventually quote
something it's a good question so let me
answer that the the general store is the
brain is extremely plastic and it shifts
its real estate to take care of whatever
the most informational irrelevant
stimulus is so you know if you go if you
go blind if I just put a very tight
blindfold on you for ninety minutes we
can start seeing activity in your visual
cortex that's responding things like
touch and sound and vocabulary words and
selectively so there's very rapid
shifting and take over in your brain and
it all matters it all as I said it's
about what is informational irrelevant
so depending on the kind of information
you're feeding in your brain will put
some of the three sources to that the
interesting part is what we don't know I
think maybe it is the heart of your
question is if you you know expand the
territory devoted something you have to
shrink a little bit the other things
does that make you worse at hearing or
seeing or so on we don't know the answer
to that yet but I don't think so I think
that we've got so much territory devoted
to vision and hearing and so on doesn't
really make it doesn't really make a big
difference when you share that territory
a little bit more so asking it again in
a year and I'll be able to tell you have
a lot more data but I have a suspicion
that we might be able to add a seventh
sense in the eighth sense a nice scent
and and we still won't run into the
limits in other words all I can say
right now is we don't know what those
limits are before you start feeling like
oh my vision will blurrier now we just
don't know what those limits are but I
have a suspicion there's plenty of room
what so it's like learning different
languages right it's not as though you
learn another language and somehow you
lose your original way exactly right
exactly and that's a good example and
you know medical students I moved here
from the Texas Medical Center and I'd
often teach them and I noticed that one
of the things that was worried about was
this this constant volume idea the brain
which is if I learned one more facts I'm
good and happily that's not the brain
the way it works it again everything is
about networks of Association and as you
learn the effect you sift them into
these John
networks of other things that you know
the same thing with other senses we're
fundamentally multi-sensory creatures
and so you know when I pick this up I'm
feeling and I look at it and I listen to
it and I'm touching it and so as you
feed new senses in it's going to mesh
with other senses in interesting ways
which means that it might not even have
to take up much territory at all
interesting so I I want to ask you do I
love this idea I have no idea that you
know just being blindfold for even just
a short time the visual cortex starts
processing other information how long
does it actually learn to integrate a
new sense so for example the best how
long how many hours you have to keep it
on before you become fluent so about a
month but that's probably the longest so
in other words we start training people
on it what we have are these games where
for example the phone presents a word to
the vest
this is it and then you see two things
on the screen two words and you have to
guess that's were developed so first you
have no idea so you're making a guess
you're at chance performance but people
start improving right away and then over
the course of the next month is could
keep going up and up and up and so the
reason I mention is because there's no
sort of there's no blow noise say oh I
got the trick because it's way too
complicated it's 20 millisecond frames
and 32 motors but instead your brain
just gets really good at learning it
that takes the longest other things that
we've done or are essentially instant so
we're doing this with blindness this is
a project that we're doing a
collaboration with Google where Google
happens have lidar set up in all their
offices so they've got these displays or
radar so they know where everything is
in the room and where everybody's
walking around so we brought a blind
person there and hooked up the vest to
that stream of information so the blind
person could feel where other people are
so if you're moving around me I'm
feeling where are you moving as you get
closer I feel these stronger and I in
weaker and I can feel where but that
actually turns out to be better than our
visual yeah we've got to appeal to me
and anyway so it's just like the force I
mean they're just like Luke Skywalker
they can feel where people are moving
around and we can give directions to
people
exactly how to navigate that anyway the
point is there was zero learning curve
with that they just immediately got that
and so so it depends on the application
we've got lots of different applications
but that's come to limerence so could I
can imagine that what the vision it's
clear you're mapping the visual field ok
that's pretty obvious and you know you
like projecting it onto my body we've
found now what is the map what it would
look like so the trick is what we're
doing is capturing the sound and turning
it into you know we're capturing all the
frequencies and each one of the motors
is representing a different frequency
from low to high and so this is
precisely what your inner ear does it
captures sound which is just a
one-dimensional input on your eardrum
and it breaks it up in all different
frequencies and sends that along
different data cables to the brain so
we're dude that's that's what I mean
when I say we return the cochlea into
the torso yours capturing all the
frequencies and and so that's the part
that people we learn but again it's it's
similar the way people are in Braille or
something it passed their fingers over
bumps and then they learned to cry and
laugh so I can imagine someone even as
they're getting older and our lures
losing their hearing maybe you can
augment by wearing a vest so that as I
get older instead of having to get you
know hearing aids I could just wear best
so turns out we've solved that problem
we built a thank you very much we built
a wristband yeah and the wristband has a
microphone and it listens for the
phonemes that people start to lose as
they get high frequency hearing loss so
people mixed up F and P and s and and
these high frequency funding so the
wristband captures the phonemes and and
buzzes tell you which phoneme was so I
call this sensory cross boosting because
the idea that you're still doing most of
the work at the lower frequencies and
just getting some information about the
high frequencies and it puts them
together people can learn this the
learning curve on this is maybe five
minutes Wow amazing yeah question yes
since you mean DJ detector you've
written science fiction and you're also
a scientist so I ask you a question back
sort of in the board completely do you
see some point in the future where it
would be possible to download the
content of the brain into another body
or some other type of an element maybe a
robot or something so that the mind will
be able to have a continuity even as the
body decays okay thank you for that
great question the question was about
can download our minds and do another
substrate and let's remember that we
live in the matrix or whatever this is
an open question until we do it the
computational hypothesis of the brain
says that the stuff doesn't matter the
biological history that we're lying on
top of doesn't matter what matters is
the algorithms that are running and if
that's true if it's really just a matter
of the algorithms then yes then we
should be able to download that onto
silicon or whatever comes after silicon
and be able to run that and what's been
very interesting to me lately is this
concept of you know mother nature had to
build this out of the stuff that she had
lying around which was cells but but
it's possible I mean if you want to
actually scan the brain and make a good
3d represent that's a zettabyte of data
a zettabyte
is equal to the total computational
capacity of a whole planet right now so
it's an enormous amount of data but the
part that interests me is could we
actually figure out the fundamental
principles and replicated right in a
much more efficient manner in the same
way that when when you look at a bird
and an airplane the airplanes are so
much more efficient way of doing it you
can get across the ocean
you know rapidly that way carrying 300
people and so on so we like to figure
out the principles of the bird and made
the airplane the questions cruise figure
out the principles of rain and put it on
to some substrate obviously the
substrate needs to have plasticity
meaning it's constantly changing with
every new eccentric
person you need every word you hear it
has to be subtly changing or else oh you
don't have any memory but the
computational hypothesis might be true
and we just don't know until we actually
try it and the really weird part about
it started very last thing a weird part
about it is if we download your brain
and we say hey how you feeling there did
it work and if you say yeah I'm feel
pretty good yeah little cold in here
whatever we still don't actually know we
can't know for sure that that is
conscious if it is you and collision one
last thing there's this very interesting
moral philosophical question about if we
copy your brain and then we start this
simulators program and then we kill you
that's murder but if we kill you the
second before we transfer it then it's
just a transfer then it's you know
depending on the set which way it goes
it's like oh yeah we just transferred
your brain over to here so anyway
there's all kinds of interesting moral
conundrum Wow that's not good to think
about that so I I want to ask you a very
practical question as my last question
that wasn't well that exactly exactly
something that one can apply tomorrow
okay so we've got a lot of young people
here who are looking at you and saying
wow I I want to be this guy I want to be
sitting up here talking about all these
amazing innovations and bringing these
great ideas to life what advice do you
wish someone had given you when you were
a student I hate to say this it hurts me
a little bit but I feel like I wish
someone had told me to get out of
academia
look what left earlier you know I mean
like as an undergrad or graduate student
but I mean I ended up then following a
path of you know assistant professor
associate professors I did that for a
long time until I started realizing that
you can do things that have a major
impact and so that that's one thing
let's see what else I mean the main
thing is
- I know this sounds cheesy but to
follow your interest in a way that is
hard both academia and in business quite
hard everywhere because you have all
these structures that you're trying to
fit within but if there's something that
interests you just make sure you find
some way to follow that whether you're
doing that in writing or start a book
remake tell the show about it or you're
studying in your garage and you're
building stuff for whatever it is you're
doing just make sure that whatever that
thing is those things are that are like
really fundamentally interesting to you
that matter more than the stuff you're
doing day to day is make sure you're
pursuing that have some way to follow
that fabulous please thank me thank you
[Applause]
you